where is the Democrat Party on this
issue now they're they're full steam
ahead they are so far past Bobby Kennedy
it is not even funny it really is not
funny
because what did we say what did all the
conservatives say
we said years ago
well if you get the sexual Revolution
stuff pretty soon they're going to
redefine marriage oh no that's a
slippery slope argument that's crazy
that's not going to happen but of course
they redefine marriage so well if you
redefine marriage then pretty soon
you're going to have all of these even
more eccentric disorder kind of family
structures like polyamorous
relationships and thruples and oh
Michael that's crazy what are you
talking about and then of course that's
what we get and then what happened the
final frontier was
pretty soon these guys are going to try
to establish legal protections
for pedophilia they're going to try to
normalize pedophilia oh how dare you
suggest that
phobic how dare you say that well I
don't know I mean we're kind of seeing
it in Academia there are some prominent
academics now who have called for uh
getting rid of the term pedophile and
changing it to map minor retracted
person and they're arguing that
pedophilia is innate and therefore
because of the premises of this modern
sexual movement if something's innate if
a desire is comes from birth or in your
early years of formation then you can
never change it and you can never
suppress it it's wrong to repress your
desires and so you know we're we're
going to have to normalize this stuff
that's what we're hearing in Academia
and now it's what we're hearing
in politics that's what we're hearing in
government a Minnesota
trans identifying
Democrat lawmaker I don't even really
have to say Democrat but
that's what this guy is
he just tried to alter a bill
to protect pedophilia as a sexual
orientation
There It Is I've got the text of it
right here
Minister Minnesota statutes 2022 section
363 a03 subdivision 44 is amended to
read subdivision 44 sexual orientation
sexual orientation means having or being
perceived as having an emotional
physical or sexual attachment to another
person without regard to the sex of that
person or having or being perceived as
having an orientation for such
attachment
then it goes on or it used to go on it
said or having or being perceived as
having a self-image or identity not
traditionally associated with one's
biological maleness or femaleness sexual
orientation does not include a physical
or sexual attachment to children by an
adult that's what it read and then this
Minnesota lawmaker
tried to amend this
to cross that out
to cross out hey no we don't want that
bigoted line in there but as sexual
orientation does not include a physical
or sexual attachment to children by an
adult that's so bigoted that's so phobic
we've got to get rid of that line
I'm not making this up here it is it's
right here got the text right here
it's Minnesota State Rep is
representative Lee Finke I don't know
what his real name is some that's Lee
l-e-i-g-h sounds like one of these made
up transgender names so I don't I don't
know but anyway he's a guy who
identifies as a woman he's a member of
the democratic farmer labor party first
self-identified transgender person in
the Minnesota Legislature
and introduce this amendment in the take
pride Act
so what would it have done it would have
protected pedophilia as a sexual
orientation
protected from discrimination by the law
now
once this made headlines a few days ago
all of a sudden the Minnesota
legislators even the ones who were
generally allied with this guy
said okay we gotta correct this so they
took a vote in the house they said okay
we're still opposed to pedophilia right
and it passed by unanimous vote
so even representative Finke here
realized okay I gotta back off this pedo
stuff for now
that's good glad
they all backed off for now
this is the direction it's going in
glad they took decisive action Bud Light
could learn a lesson or two from them
you can't take this away
you can't hide the fact that this is the
direction they wanted to go in right now
text Knowles to 98 98 98 president Trump
recently issued a warning from his
Mar-A-Lago home quote our currency is
crashing will soon no longer be the
world standard which will be our
greatest defeat frankly in 200 years
there are three reasons the central
banks are dumping the US dollar
inflation deficit spending and our
insurmountable national debt the fact is
there's one asset that has withstood
famine Wars and political and economic
upheaval dating back to Biblical times
that is gold and you can own it in a tax
sheltered retirement account with the
help of Birch gold that is right Birch
gold will help you convert an existing
Ira or 401K maybe from a previous
employer into an IRA into gold the best
part you don't pay a penny out of pocket
just text Knowles kwles to 98 98 98 for
your free info kit they will hold your
hand through the whole process think
about this when currencies fail gold is
a safe haven how much more time does the
Dollar have protect your savings with
gold Birch gold has an eight plus rating
with the Better Business Bureau
thousands of happy customers text
Knowles Canada wlas to 98 98 98 get your
free info kit on gold text Knolls it's
98 98.98 now speaking of pedophilia
Governor Ron DeSantis it would appear to
be soon to be presidential candidate Ron
DeSantis
has come out
and pushed for the death penalty for
pedophiles in Florida
these are really the worst of the worst
and what happens is the perpetrators
crimes are oftentimes serial offenders
and if someone does uh one if they if
they rape a child uh like and these are
very young very young children sometimes
like six seven eight years old if they
do that once chances are they will do it
again unless they're stopped unless
they're incapacitated and so we really
believe that part of a just Society is
to have appropriate punishment and so if
you commit a crime that is um really
really heinous you should have the
ultimate punishment and so what this
bill does is it challenges uh the U.S
Supreme Court for recently deciding
probably six or seven years ago they
decided by five to four after over 200
years of our of our constitution being
uh in in place that somehow you could
never have capital punishment meant for
crimes like rape
and so Ron DeSantis says we're
challenging that now if you uh rape a
child pretty much the most heinous crime
you can imagine you get the death
penalty totally agree with that in
principle I see no problem with that in
principle I see no problem with the
death penalty in principle in fact I
think it's uh quite natural biblical you
see it defended by some of the greatest
Minds in the history of the church and
it not only defended but even enacted by
some of the great popes in history so
there's nothing unchristian
about it there's nothing immoral about
it
and there's nothing unconstitutional
about it in the early days of our
country
the the definition of a felony was that
you would hang for it the death penalty
was widely applied much more widely than
it is today I don't actually agree with
this particular instantiation of the
death penalty in practice in principle I
do but in practice the only reason I
don't is that as a matter of prudence if
you don't
kill child rapists if the punishment is
not execution then it creates some
incentive for the rapist not to murder
his victim
so if there's any way that through the
law we can incentivize a rapist not to
murder his victim I think that's
probably wise and prudent
in principle they deserve death
certainly uh but putting all of that
aside for a second the difference
between the the law and principle and in
practice the main thing about the story
that's interesting is
what governor DeSantis was standing in
front of he was not standing in front of
the flag of the State of Florida he was
not holding a regular press conference
with some signs behind him he was
standing in front of a big gigantic
American flag because he's obviously
about to announce this run for president
he is pushing for this
law that will obviously be almost
universally popular I guess not among
the pedo Defenders and and against and
and there are some people who are
thinking about this issue I think in a a
little more of a
wise as a serpent innocent as a dove
kind of way who are talking about the
actual practical effects but broadly
speaking execute pedos is a very popular
campaign slogan and so putting the the
meat of the law side for a second what
this is signaling is this guy is moving
full steam ahead and we can expect a
campaign announcement soon I know I know
what you're thinking that was a great
clip I'm with you if you want the whole
show you got to subscribe if you want
all that extra content you got to ring
that Bell ding that dong collect that
thing subscribe to the Michael Knowles
YouTube channel we'll see you next time
[Music]